[Music]
hello everyone and welcome
to talk about it you the cloud I am
olivier rossini clad consultants based at
google paris during a series
of episodes we will discuss the
different points to consider when
migrating  applications to google
cloud
for this we will take a
very simple example irène and claude are
passionate about handmade knitting and
everything related to wool in general
wishing to communicate their passion
with as many people as possible
they have created a website in  2014 this
fantastic knitting website contains a
discussion forum for this they
subscribed to an online hosting offer
to deploy their
php applications on a linux apache and mysql server
here we are in 2018 and their website has
made it possible to create a  community of
hundreds of thousands of people who
share and discuss their common passion
in the face of growing demand irène and
claude have decided to step up a gear
by transforming their passion
into a real business and launching
a marketplace with the increase
in traffic to their websites,
scalability problems appear even if to support this
growing traffic they have increased the
initial capacity of their servers he
anticipates that the  adding the future marketplace will
require more
resources
the cost and management of an
increasing number of machines on the
current hosting platform is a
heavy workload and an
obstacle for them having heard
of google cloud platform its
competitive prices  and its ease of use
they decided to test it a
migration to the cloud can be approached
in several ways
one can either reproduce the same
architecture without any modification
in the code of the application or
reconsider the architecture modify the
source code in order  to take advantage of
all the capabilities of the cloud platform
in this episo  from we will
first see the first approach
based on google computing in we
start from a simple application
made with wordpress and based
on a linux stack apache mysql php
we want to migrate this application
to google cloud without modifying
code nina architecture so the first
question is what size of
virtual machines cpu mm
wow am i going to have to choose google cloud
gives you the flexibility
to fit your
cpu and memory needs let's
quickly look at how when choosing the
size of vm
we distinguish two main classes the
predefined machines and the
personalized machines among the
predefined machines there are three main types of
vm it is the shared actor and that for
a classic use and it is the
optimized memory
let us take d  First the example of predefined vms
for classic use
we have the choice between
standard configurations even
privileged  ant a high memory capacity
and a cpu favoring a
high cpu capacity
these configurations are available in
all regions and zones which is the
ideal case to ensure high
availability and low network latency
this is the type of virtual machine that
we will use here now let's look at
how to deploy the stack
lamp on google cloud
several possibilities exist either
automatically deploy from the
marketplace the solutions pre-packaged
by our partners and by google or
manually deploy a vm with the
stack lamp
among the pre-packaged solutions on the
marketplace  you will find for example
a deployment of the stack lamp on a
single machine or a deployment in high
availability on several machines
with a batch of greenhouse balloons
in front first we will see
how to use the packaged solutions
present on the marketplace we
were managing for  this in
google clo console  ud in the marketplace section
and search by keywords
for our case we find for
example solutions for deploying
wordpress either on a
simple architecture with a single machine or on a
high availability architecture
choose the basic solution with one
machine and click on deployed  on
complete in jean
if we had chosen a more
evolved architecture with several machines a lot of
bouncer and cloud sql
we could have had to
update more parameters such as for
example the name of minimum and
maximum machine for an automatic dimensioning roe
depending on the load
the sql cloud configuration or the
number and size of storage disks
after validating these parameters
everything is automatically created deployed
and is ready to use on our
google
cloud project now we will use the
second  method which consists in creating an
environment without starting from a
pre-packaged solution that con  therefore,
there are instances of one or more
virtual machines on computer jean
and deploy the stack lamp there
from the google cloud console we are
going to create a vm in our project
we choose the size of the vm a
cpu and 3.75 gigabytes of memory  which is
enough for now note in
passing that the interaction with google
cloud can be done via the web console
that we use here or in
command line with the sdk ji cloud to
connect to the
vm you just have to start  an
ssh session from the web console
now let's install apache and php let's test that
the installation is functional for that
we locate the public ip address of the vm
and we access it from the browser
we see the apache server configuration page
to check  that php works well
with apache we will create an
html test file containing a very simple php code
by accessing this web page we make sure
that it displays the information of
the environment  on apache
the next step will be the installation of
mysql
then using the command mysql
secure installations we can
configure mysql to improve the
security of the deployment this allows to
specify the password of the user route
and to delete the anonymous user
we now have to transfer the
data from the old environment to
the target environment different
solutions exist to migrate the
content of your application from
the original environment to
the target environment of course in the
case of wordpress we could  use
an extension that manages this for us if
you have to manage this operation by
yourself you are
probably wondering how to copy data
to google keep the
easiest and most secure way and to use
google cloud storage and its cloud api
storage is a
distributed storage system for storing your
data securely and durably
on google cloud in  s what are
called beuquettes with the
useful gs cp command you can transfer
the export of your
mysql database or any other file to cloud storage you
can then see in the
google clad console that the file has been
transferred to  this case I am the only one
authorized to read and write in this
cloud storage budget and you can control
and configure access rights via
identity and access management iam
allows you to manage identities and
access to the various
google cloud resources to retrieve the  data
on my target vein so all I have to do
from the bm is to copy the data from
the cloud storage budget to a
local directory the data from my site is
now copied to my
google cloud environment on my virtual machine and
I also have a  durable archive
of this data so we were able to
see during this episode how to use
computer inc to create a
virtual machine and deploy an application on it
in the following episodes
we will see together how to enrich
this target architecture via
features offered by google
cloud including security network
automatic resizing
monitoring and many more
thank you for your attention and see you soon
[Music]